más de un millón de trabajadores se
lanzaron a las calles en la segunda
marcha convocada por los sindicatos
franceses para protestar contra el
aumento de la edad de jubilación
propuesta por el presidente Emmanuel
macron sectores como los de las
refinerías el transporte público y las
escuelas hicieron parte de la
movilización
nos enfrentamos Un gobierno que por el
momento quiere imponer las cosas y le
decimos que comportarse así no tiene
salida hay que escuchar la movilización
histórica Me atrevo a decir que hoy 31
de enero de 2023 tenemos una de las
mayores manifestaciones que se han
organizado en nuestro país desde hace
décadas
las multitudes marcharon por ciudades
como París Marsella León James y
montpellier y se espera que en febrero
vuelvan a las calles
La intersindical Llama a toda la
población a movilizarse mediante huelgas
y manifestaciones aún más masivas el
martes siete de febrero Y luego el
sábado 11 de febrero para decir no a
esta reforma de aquí entonces Llama a
multiplicar las acciones iniciativas
reuniones o asambleas generales en todo
el territorio
los sondeos de opinión muestran que una
mayoría sustancial se opone a la reforma
pero el gobierno se mantiene firme la
primera ministra Elizabeth born ha
declarado que el umbral de los 64 años
es negociable la reforma del sistema de
pensiones supondrían Un aumento de
19.180 millones de dólares en las
cotizaciones anuales según el Ministerio
del trabajo